uh so um
in the last hour i was talking about the
complexity of computing uh local min max
equilibrium
local uh nash equilibria and you know
the hardness result already held for
local min max equilibrium so let me give
a
you know let me explain i i gave you
some intuition
about why even an extra player in a
non-concave game
can make even local solutions
intractable
and you know i made this comment that uh
sort of like we have intuition about how
we would like to you know
uh uh
approve our uh uh uh at least query
complexity lower bound uh
but uh we didn't know how to do it
before you know
uh unless we uh first uh build uh a
complexity proof and then uh appeal to
that to put the properties of that to
get the lord to the curry lure one so
let me discuss a little bit
you know the types of techniques that
uh
uh we we know we use
uh and the reason uh i think this is uh
interesting if you haven't seen this
kind of uh arguments is because like
typically in a ml when you want to prove
a query complexity lower bound like the
one
uh i stated earlier like this one here
that uh
uh uh any first order method
and you know need exponentially many
steps to do something
uh you know
uh typically um
in optimization you don't use the kinds
of tools that uh
we use here so let me explain a little
bit you know what tools we're using you
know
what is their mathematical nature
so these tools are ultimately
topological
and
they relate to fixed points and
combinatorial arguments that are useful
improving
fixed point theorems
and let me present to you a
variant of the classical sperner lemma
which is used to prove
brower serum so
this is not the original
spurner lemon it's a variant that we
that is convenient for us to use for our
purposes
here's the idea and i'm showing it in
two dimensions you can generalize it to
any dimension
so in two dimensions you're gonna have
two colors the four colors in and d
dimensions you're gonna have two times d
colors so in two dimensions you're
thinking about the greed the square
green
and you're gonna be coloring the
vertices of the grid with this you know
four colors like red blue
orange and green
and
the boundary has to look like you see in
the picture
so i fixed the boundary coloring to be
that
the claim is that no matter how you
color the internal vertices
[Music]
there's going to be
at least one square
where you're going to do
where you're going to see
[Music]
red and yellow together or blue and
green together or both
now there are four colors
uh
that i'm using here
and
there are six pairs of these four colors
out of the six pairs of these four
colors
four pairs are trivial because they come
together already in the boundary
right so like blue red come together
here
and so forth right so four out of the
six combos of colors
pairs of colors come together at the
boundary
the claim of the lemma is that the
non-trivial ones
will come together no matter how you
color the insides
so for example if you were to color it
inside in this way
there's a square where
uh red and uh okay this is yellow okay
so red and yellow come together
and blue and green together all right
so that's the claim
so so so so let me try to prove it
uh okay let me forget about the location
of that uh square where cool things
happen is that a question
you don't need both
and
yeah or forward so happens in my picture
that there is one square where both
combos arise but the claims are at least
one
there's going to be at least one square
where at least
for either red and yellow are going to
come together or sorry
where red yellow going together or blue
and green or both okay
okay so let me forget about that's
square where it is and
tell me not to prove that there is such
a thing
to prove it i'm going to imagine this is
a factory
and the factory has square rooms
every room has four pillars that are
colored with this four color with you
know different colors
and i'm gonna do a walk in this factory
and i'm gonna enter the factory through
this door here into that room over here
okay
so
that door no matter how you color the
inside of the square
that door is certainly a red blue door
and i'm entering into the factory
having through a red blue door with red
on my left
all right so now i enter into a room
uh and you know uh
well and then you know i find another
red blue door that i can cross with red
on my left and i do that
okay
and i keep going
so my
modus operandis
is that
i will enter rooms through a red blue
door
having red on my left
i will mark the door that i use to enter
those rooms
and if i can find another red blue door
that i can use to exit
having red on my left
uh the the room i will cross a door and
mark it okay this is my modus operandi
uh
so
you know i keep going inside this
factory
crossing red blue doors and
uh and and like crossing them out
another question is what's going to
happen into my walk okay let me let me
make some observations
first observation is that we'll never
exit the factory
the reason i will never exit the factor
is that there is no red blue door on the
boundary that i can cross to exit the
factory having uh
red on my left hand side there's only
one red blue door and that's here
and that red door cannot be used to exit
let alone that i will you know if
because the first time i cross it i mark
it i will never use it again anyways but
that's so i will never exit the factor
because i have to stay inside
uh
the other uh observation i'm gonna make
is of course you know this factor is uh
finite there's a finite number of doors
overall so
uh you know i never cross a door that i
have marked so my my work has to stop
okay so
some will not exit and i will have to
stop somewhere now let's understand
where i start
third observation i'm going to have
we're going to make is the following
right the following like no matter how
you color a square with these four
colors
that square can have
either four red blue doors
or two red blue doors
or one redwood door you cannot have
three red blue doors interesting enough
and also
if it has four red blue doors it has
exactly two doors that you can use to
enter into the room with uh red on your
left and two doors that you can use to
exit the room with
red on your left
so this i cannot be possibly rooms where
i stop
because the first time i enter them i
mark the door that i used and there is
definitely an exit door
and if i ever come back to them there's
always there will be an exit door again
because there are four doors exactly
two entrances and two exits okay
the same is true for rooms with two red
blue doors
if a room has two redwood doors exactly
two one is an entrance and one is an
exit so that's also not a room where you
can stop
all right
so my room cannot exit
he will have to stop
he cannot stop at a room with
exactly two or exactly four red blue
doors so it has to stop at a room
with exactly one red blue door
now guess what these rooms are these are
rooms where
red and yellow meat or blue and green
meat
and this is what's happening here
so this is a proof of spareness lemma
now you can use this la this is a very a
variant of the cloud more classical
lemma you can generalize to many
dimensions and you can use this to prove
various fixment theorems so it is
intimately related to complexity theory
in fact if your access to the colors of
this factor if this is a big factor and
you access the colors through a circuit
it is pretty complete hard to find uh
to identify uh rooms with where the
right combos of colors meet
all right what does this have to do with
mid max
um
well uh
imagine you know
we're in many dimensions but imagine
along some dimensions you have a
minimization minimizing player's moves
along the other direction of maximizer
so so let me show the picture for two
dimensions
uh what does it have to do with sperner
well
imagine that you know like i look at my
loss function and i compute this uh
gradient field
uh and right so i take the minus
gradient with respect to the x player
and the plus gradient vector y player
and look at the direction in which this
vector field is
and use the windows colors to uh
to color that node okay so for every
point over here
okay let's discretize it
uh we compute the direction of the
gradients
and color that point using those you
know depending on the direction of that
color
you may see a picture like this
and okay like uh
suppose that if you do that
the color the boundary coloring
satisfies the spurner
properties if it doesn't
uh you can argue that uh the problem
becomes lower dimensional so at some
point you're gonna
you know
unravel that and stop at a place where
you can actually
argue that this boundary coloring works
so let's say that it works for our
two-dimensional picture
so
if the preconditions of sperner's lemma
hold
there must be a point where
uh
red meets yellow or blue means green
okay
and then we have arranged the the colors
like if these two guys meet
both sides of the x gradient coexist in
a small
neighborhood and both sides of the y
gradient coexist in the in a small
neighborhood
if either of these combos
coexist in a square imagine these scores
are very very very tiny
if either of these combos if this combo
exists in a small locale or this combo
exists in a small locale then all the
signs of the two gradients coexist in a
small locale and that's enough for a min
max equilibrium
and the coexistence is guaranteed by
spurner's lemon
right so this is how you can
map min max optimization
to finding spurner
squares
what are the car
what are the carriers
the windows
uh so the colors uh
depending on the direction of this
gradient field
uh depending on where it points you're
gonna call like hit this vertex you go
to this vertex you compute this gradient
field and if it points this way you're
gonna in any of these angles
in the positive ortho you call it red
okay in this open you go with the blue
and so forth
okay so now if it so happens that you
powder
using this uh uh
protocol
and the boundary satisfies furnace
constraints for the dilemma constraints
then spreader guarantees that there is a
neighborhood where all the colors meet
not all the colors and the
uh
and
if you get uh
red and yellow coexisting
then uh
at the right point you have uh these
signs for both gradients
and in the other point you have these
signs for so that you have for both x
and y both the plus and the minus
direction coexisting so that's enough
for a local nash
sense
so in fact if in a small neighborhood
right in this point for example
uh you point this way and at this point
you point that way
then uh
for the x player in a small neighborhood
imagine this is like very tiny this is
like the leg here is tiny in a small
local you have a point
where uh you know you have both sides
for the x player
and
also both sides for the y player that's
enough for a local match
right now if the boundary coding as i
was saying does not satisfy strains
you can map that down to a third
dimensional problem and you can continue
to eventually uh if you can actually
uh
you know map it to a permanent instance
uh in fact this is what we do in the
recent work with uh uh
manolis uh
sabotage and satisfys
so what we do is we actually inspired by
this mapping from a local min max
optimization
tooth burner
we take the sizes of these squares to
zero
and that gives rise gives rise to a
continuous time dynamic that we call
scd okay not gd
spurner continuous dynamics
scd
which is a second order method with the
following property that
it is guaranteed to get to a local minox
equilibrium
so prior to this work there was no
dynamic known to
exhibit
guaranteed convergence to
local minmax equilibria there is a
paper
called follow the ridge which has
exhibits local convergence our method is
closely related to follow the reach but
it has the property that it has a
guaranteed convergence to
the local minmax equilibrium
albeit is not going to be efficient
because the problem is intractable right
so
we're not going to
solve ppid
but we have at least guaranteed
convergence maybe coming back to the
practical questions that were asked
earlier
uh you know you can try a cd in your
setting
uh scd is sensitive to
second order uh uh properties of uh
uh your function and
you know it you know like if it finds uh
if it finds places where it's smooth it
telescopes fast inside the domain so
it's possible that in practice
if you know like if your domain is not
very rugged that this method
could
be a nice method to run
manually
my question is the turning because
how much smooth is
i don't know what is the issue but i
feel that there is an issue
when we do the test because yeah
so that there is yeah so there is like
the direction in which you move
uh has to do with you know like you know
certain hessians that you complete along
the way
and uh you know if these guys are smooth
there is a discontinuity in the then
there's nothing that's convenient you
know
so it's gonna be i mean it's gonna it's
a
um
you know
it depends on properties of essence of
your uh yeah if you have uh very small
uh eigenvalues of you know
uh things that you may have sharper
terms but
[Music]
that came in my mind like
non-differentiability
maybe it's no that's just a picture
sorry i remember from uh old-fashioned
spurner that there were an odd number of
triangles right yeah and i assume
there's an odd number or something like
that here and so i don't know how much
topology we're gonna have to learn in
the future
kind of read out structural properties
yeah yeah so you're right
yeah all right so spanners
yeah the spreader spurning triangles are
going pair they're going personally
they're not one are left out so there's
an odd number of them there are
triangles that's uh yes over here they
also come in pairs so uh
but
here you have twice as many as you would
have in the normal experiments then you
you
you lose a bit of that but they are
oriented so you can recover it if you
look at the orientations of your space
so that this structure is pretty likely
they have something to say about nash
local mesh how many local labs there are
no
[Music]
right so this was intuition like why
spreader is central in computing local
nashes the question is
why are local masses as hard as any
problem in this class
some intuition about that well you have
to go in the reverse you have to start
with an instance of sperner like the one
you see here and you have to construct a
smooth
uh
non-concave two-player zero sum game
such that if you find the local nash
equilibria there you recover sperner
squares in your instance you started
with
which would imply the ppd completeness
result i want to prove
so roughly speaking the
so we're not going to assign this
dimension to one player and this
dimension is the other player that's not
going to be what's happening
instead of what we're gonna do roughly
speaking
what i'm about to present is not gonna
be a smooth function but uh
it's good intuition
roughly speaking
one player's job
is gonna be to choose squares
the other player's job is going to be to
choose doors
on those queries chosen by the other
player this is where the constraints
come into play
and the rewards have to do with
the color and the orientation of the
door that the door player chose in the
square of the of the square play
roughly speaking okay
and uh you know the complication is that
you know this is a discrete problem
but my you know the target problem is to
find
equilibrium smooth games so how do you
turn turn this
uh
idea
into an instance of a smooth uh two
player zero sum game and that's where a
lot of the work goes in this paper
yeah we have to do a lot of work to
uh
uh you know take uh you know kind of
like a discrete construction map it to a
smooth pro a smooth
uh uh objective function in high
dimensions so so you know doing smooth
interpolation in high dimension is not
as easy as
you may think
like that
just creating lipsticks yeah yeah yeah
uh and they come to do it in a
computational efficient way right
because in the high dimensions you have
a d dimensional cubelet
and it's exponentially many corners
so the obvious construction is not going
to work for you so you have to divide
into simplices but these simplices have
boundaries and as you traverse
boundaries you may lose the smoothness
if you if if you do the standard
interpolation so a lot of work goes
there how to
uh
how to interpolate in high dimensions
uh
without violating smoothness
all right so that's roughly speaking uh
what i had on the complexity front
but what i want to draw from that then
you know like
i don't throw
tomatoes or eggs at me
but uh i want to draw a philosophical
correlation out of this
all right michael has had
because of this complexity results that
arise in computing local nash equilibria
we cannot
extend the deep learning paradigm
simply
to the multi-agent setting
uh because we cannot just say look i'm
gonna endow all my agents with the
ability to run great in descent
give them complex models give them
utility functions and let them grade and
descend the hell out of it
uh the complex result says that
you know in principle it could take
exponential time to converge so you know
do we want our tension flow to converge
in exponential time no okay so
uh we have to be a bit smarter about the
situation at hand we have to do a lot
more work we cannot just blindly
come up with any model we want
you know gradient descent the hell out
of it okay that's my point
and i think we have to do a lot more
work in modeling the setting
uh choosing the right learning model
like the architecture of our agents
deciding what are meaningful solution
concepts maybe it's local nash maybe
something else you guys will define it
during the semester
this program
and uh
designing the optimization market will
get there
and i think only then we will get to
more successes like you know alphago and
librettus
because you know if you look inside them
i mean this the use is not
deep learning like liberators uses no
deep learning
and alphago uses deep learning but they
use also
monte carlo 3 search and other game
theoretical ideas for how to how you
optimize strategies in min max around
the
turn-based uh problems so
my claim philosophical corollary is that
you have to work a bit harder you cannot
just be agnostic about everything and
uh i hope to
succeed with you completely
concepts are really necessary for us to
really impact the real world for sure
it's not that kind that's not in real
life what we really like is that we
trust people around us we build drugs
and build coalitions and all that so
actually i think most of the cool new
solution concepts and now for sure
i mean
this model in the setting is exactly
what we should focus on like we cannot
just uh hope to solve everything in the
world we have to think about what we're
trying to solve
uh build the right uh frameworks
uh to do so uh hopefully agree
yeah can i ask a technical question you
said that the uh
if you have the gradient
it's exponential
but that is not the constitutional uh
it's a very complex thing
yeah so it does not come from the
equivalence right it does but yeah so
you have to work harder for those as it
turns out
this reduction this computational
hardness is deduction
it has an extra property it's a black
box reduction so you can use kind of
like you can take the circuit of
screener
and with um
clearly access to it
construct the
uh uh uh you know the the the the make a
circuit that computes the
uh uh uh the objective function in the
game and because uh complex nervous
exists for spreader you can inherit them
for uh
for um for for midnight's optimizations
but that's it that's a very insightful
uh question
uh very quickly it just came in my mind
so it would be interesting to check if i
have access also
just
more derivatives if the problem can
become easier so the yeah so the method
that i mentioned with the
new algoliwicz uh and my knowledge and
strategies
this one uses uh higher order uh
information
uh
and you know as i was saying earlier
kind of like
if you're sufficiently smooth he also
allows you to telescope in the space
which also relates to the point that
mike said that you know things are not
worst case maybe there's more smoothness
and i my method can
um
the problem in that case is not
intractable given that i have i don't
have guarantees that it is interactable
i don't do because
i mean like i think that
already holds even become white blocks
access to negativity
so the hardness the computational
hardness is we have white books access
with the blackboard
[Music]
all right so let's start jumping off
point for my next uh
part
so let me uh get into that like uh
we have to do a little work we have to
understand the settings we're just
installing so you know what should we do
okay
and i wanted to discuss a little bit
extensive from games stochastic gains
and low complexity
let me start with an executive summary
of what i uh planning to discuss and i'm
going to cover as much as i can in the
remaining you know 35 minutes or so
okay so what's up with uh okay so let's
uh you know continuing you know the same
token from previous hour
okay what what you know what what will
become of local nash okay
okay it's very intractable
but uh you know as i was saying you can
exploit this connection to sperner and
the and the types of algorithms that
sold spurner to construct the second
order methods
and the secondary methods use uh the
hessian and if the hessian is smooth
maybe you can expect that in
reasonable scenarios this scd method may
work well
um
another thing that i find interesting is
how to
convert this second order mess to first
order by
you know by by by kind of like you know
with first order uh access to your
function uh
you know you know
could construct an approximation to your
hessium
all right so so turn them into a method
excuse me and vector method you mean
yeah do stuff like that to turn them
into first order hands more efficient
and uh you know coming back to mike's
point you know identify
beyond worst case complexity type of uh
structure
under which
the problem is not controlled
at this level of gender value
another thing that if i actually cool is
the following a lot of our trouble with
local nash even in two players zero sum
games
is that the problem is being max
uh so it's a fixed point problem it
becomes a fixed point problem if you
have non-concavity so you lose the
connection to convex optimization that
you have if it's convex concave
um
but you know there are other solution
concepts in economics that are not fixed
point like like correlated equilibrium
one thing that i find very interesting
is
what is a local notion of correlation
how do you define a solution concept
where
your agent's actions are correlated
but in a local sense you don't want to
of course you don't want to have a
global correlation over a high
dimensional space but
what are uh interesting notions of
correlations that that
are stable at the local scale i find it
an interesting
uh
thing to think about
this is on the local uh
side
rabbit global side okay so like
game theory is like convexifying things
so is there a way to convexify my way
out of the issue
um
you know as i said you know like if you
don't go like like like you know like
you know if people choose you know uh
continuous actions uh the problem is you
know the equilibrium may not exist but
maybe i can uh
i do i can find the existence if i go to
randomizations over this high
dimensional space okay this
convexify the problem
uh so what i want to talk about is some
recent work with nargolo which uh
where we show that the minimax theorem
holds
and the course correlated equilibrium
exists if you consider randomizations
over these high dimensional spaces
as long as you avoid certain bad
structures that prevent equilibrium
existence
don't read this i will get to it in in
in
two slides don't read that those
conditions
uh and we also get no regret learning
dynamics that have fast rates uh getting
to those uh solutions
uh that's another thing that i wanna
touch upon
and finally uh
it's very interesting to see special
game classes that
you know sidestep uh
the interactability barriers and one
important one are stochastic games
sarcastic games go back to shapley's
seminal paper in the 50s
and have received a lot of work in game
theory and also recently as a model of
multi-agent reinforcement learning
so in these games
an important concept that i'm going to
discuss are stationary markov equilibria
and stationary markov
strategies
interestingly the utilities of agents
uh with respect to this stationary
markov strategies are non-concave
nevertheless equilibrium exists
right so
it's in an it's a non-concave game with
respect to the stationary markov
strategies
nevertheless global equilibria exists
with respect to the stationary mark of
strategies so there's a lot of structure
in this i think despite the fact that
it's not concave
and i think it's an interesting uh
place where
uh you know progress should should be
made
i'm gonna talk about uh that uh
in a little bit
okay
so this is uh
the executive summary but let's so let
me dive into a few of these ideas okay
so let's
don't worry about the rest of the
details on this slide
let me first talk about uh
infinitely large games
and global equilibria in this infinitely
large games
right
is it possible to
compute or learn equilibria in this when
the game has infinitely many
uh actions and you can see the
randomizations over these infinitely
many
actions how do you approach this problem
uh uh given the fact that uh you know
typical uh rates uh for no regret
learning uh
depend logarithmically in the number of
actions right so now i'm thinking about
infinitely many actions
so i i cannot just use these algorithms
uh
for that purpose
right so can we get
uh learning in games with limited many
uh actions if
the game has low complexity and we have
to understand what is a notion of low
complexity for infinitely large games so
that
equilibrium existence holds and
equilibria are approachable by
learning methods
uh note that in the
statistical setting when we learn from
iid data it is possible
to avoid paying log number of hypotheses
and place something that depends on the
vc dimension of the function class you
want to prove
uniform convergence for
so on the statistical side of things we
have experience where we don't need to
pay in our sample complexity bounds
logarithmically in the number of
hypotheses to get uniform convergence so
can we replicate that picture in the in
the game setting
uh there are issues okay and the issue
comes in the form of this guess the
larger number game it's a two-player
zero-sum game
uh where you know one agent proposes a
number the other agent simultaneously
proposes another whoever proposes a
bigger number wins
uh so
uh this is the utility of the purple
player in this game
let's say that we tie breaks in favor of
that purple player
if
players play the upper
triangle the purple player wins a point
otherwise they'll lose a point
and the problem is that this game has no
nash equilibrium even an approximate one
i mean i hope this is obvious well if
it's not here's a little proof so
suppose
a strategy p a you know a distribution
over natural numbers for the rope layer
and the distribution of the natural
numbers for the column is a you know a
quarter approximate
mass equilibrium
and suppose that uh without loss of
generality
the game is in fa under this pair of
services in favor of the purple player
otherwise i would do the symmetric
argument for the other so let's say that
in this approximate nash equilibrium the
purple player more often wins than loses
so the val the value the utility
receives at least zero
if that's the case okay so of course of
course you can always find
uh
a number x
that is bigger than a big chunk of the
support of the purple player you can
choose you can choose a number way way
down
so that
let's say four fifths of the support of
the purple player is below that number
and you know if you were to switch there
you would definitely uh
uh
you need this many at least this many
fraction of the time
currently you win lower than zero now
you will win that so you are improving
by more than a quarter
uh so yeah so this game does not have
nash equilibrium so what am i going to
do right so i'm thinking about
infinitely
infinite games and even when the game
has a countable number of strategies
and it's zero sum and to player i lose
equilibrium
um
uh so surprising fact
this guess the larger number game is the
only obstacle for equilibrium existence
in two players zero sum games
right so any
uh
uh two player zero sum games with
potentially the uncountably infinite
actions for the two play many actions
for the two players
if it does not contain this guess the
larger number game then it will have a
min max equilibrium and actually the min
max theorem will hold
so a result by hanneke livni and moran
from uh last year
says exactly that that if you have
an infinite game
uh that does not how contains a sub game
that looks like the
uh uh i guess the larger number game
then it has an epsilon approximate nash
equilibrium a minimax equilibrium for
any epsilon you want
now which games have no such
okay not having this i guess the larger
number game inside you what does it mean
for you right what are sufficient
conditions
are there any reasonable you know
conditions under which you don't have
this game inside you
here's a sufficient condition so
if your little stone dimension is
bounded
uh
and i will i will postpone a little bit
to the next slide what this means uh
then you don't have the guess the larger
numbering
and also this condition having a bonded
little dimension in a sense is uh
almost necessary and uh you can look at
more details in the paper within algolo
which and also
nika tomorrow is going to talk about
that a lot yes just very quickly
the diagonal that it is not zero
does it matter a lot or not that is not
zero oh i just wanted to have a binary
game uh okay yeah for this slide i'll
i'll give you here's a theorem for
general
this is the
real value generalization these are
boolean gains minus plus minus sales
and zero sum
this is zero sum but real value
uh so what we show is that um
uh
this can be generalized
uh as long as we don't obtain a scaling
of the
in some precise sense
without a scaling
a scaled version you don't contain a
scaled version of this again
all right so uh these are the
interesting results that i wanted to
talk about uh
let me explain a little bit uh at least
for the boolean case what this means so
this is a little bit has to go through
sequential radomir complexity so let's
postpone that to the paper but let me
describe a little bit what it means for
a game to have finite little song
dimension
uh
what is a little some dimension of the
game
okay so here is our setting
we have a boolean valid game plus minus
one
with a bunch of players i'm going to
define the thing for multiplayer games
as opposed to two player zero sum so you
have a
and player game with utilities are plus
minus ones boolean utilities
and
for every player
you consider a hypothesis class
that uh it's a boolean because this
takes values plus or minus one it's a
boolean function here
and this function is indexed by the
action of the player so there's one one
function for every action of the player
so
the potentially uncountable infinite
actions of the pair so they're
potentially uncountably infinite
utilities in here but it's uh
uh x i that you play
uh defines a boolean function
on the strategies of the other guys
that's a hypothesis class you can define
and the levels of dimension of the game
is going to be the maximum of the little
stone dimensions of these
function classes that i created this way
so create a function class per player
i look at the little dimension of each
of them the maximum of them is the
little subdimension of the game
now how do you define in many cases
you're not familiar with this concept
it's a concept of learnability in online
learning what is a little dimension of a
function class
uh the way you define it is you consider
uh
trees decision trees like the one you
look here where you query available and
depending on its value you go left or
right
and you know going left you create
another variable you go left and right
depending on the
uh
[Music]
function output and
uh so so what you want is that you want
okay so we say that such a tree is
shattered
by a function class if for every leaf of
that tree
there is a utility function there is a
there is a there is a hypothesis that uh
uh you know satisfy
uh you know that that uh for example you
know like for the for the you know green
path to be implementable
you need a utility function that if you
quit on this point uh it says minus one
if you quit on this point it says plus
one
if you query it on this point it says
plus one so
uh uh this tree is gonna be shattered by
this function class if i can get to any
leaf if i choose the right hypothesis in
my function class
so now the deeper the you know
the the the deeper i can uh
the the you know the length of animation
is how deep i can make that uh tree uh
so that it's still shattered by my
uh hypothesis class
correct yeah
yeah
yeah you wouldn't gain much from that
though i mean uh
in fact uh you sh
shouldn't do that because
this is certainly not going to be a
complete binary tree if you do that so
you shouldn't do that you want you so
right so what i want is the biggest
complete binary tree the deepest
complete binary tree
such that every leaf i can get to
if i pick the right hypothesis in my
class
and you know go down by creating this
hypothesis
okay that's a definition okay so
it takes a while to parse but
it is important for online learning
[Music]
and
[Music]
here's a result that we can establish
that
not only min max equilibrium holds
if a game has finite little some
dimension but also we can replicate the
types of rate that surgane satal get for
finite gains
in this infinitely large
games so
there are algorithms there are no regret
learning algorithms
that converge
to equilibrium
with a rate with a regret that's you
know does not go like group t but that
grows like t to the one fourth
and a little stone dimension of the
function class at the front
uh
so yeah so that's not explicitly depend
on the number of actions that you have
available you have infinitely many
uncountably many actions and uh what the
convergence here means if you're in a
zero-sum game you convert to minimax
equilibrium
even if you're in a multiplayer game you
convert to a course correlated
equilibrium of the game
so effectively what results say is that
if you avoid this guess the larger
number game inside you if you don't have
if you do not contain that against a
larger number game
then
equilibria exists like min max or course
correlated libra exist
and you can arrive at those equilibria
we have no regret learning at the fast
rates that we know
from sirgani citadel
for finite games
we haven't
improved those to the most recent
results that i talked about earlier
which where this is poly lochte yet okay
so we have not
we have not used this higher order
smoothness technology to
bring this down to poly loctite but uh
you know this is the first step yes so
to understand what is an algorithm here
so you keep a distribution over actions
and yes
yes how you update your distribution you
say i'm using no regretting right so how
you update in one step how you update
your distribution it is complex it is
quite complicated
algorithm is efficient you have to do
you have to operate on the whole
function sure sure
i'm just putting down the rates here
the lack of general summing the two
players
is something because
i'm just
if you're a two-player general son you
fall under this capital you're going to
cross correlate it um
so that's the first thing i wanted to
talk about
second chapter stochastic games aka and
also as a model of multi-agent
reinforcement
uh because that's on the previous one do
you have anything on oracle based type
of assumptions here like
yeah i mean i mean
if you look at our algorithm it makes
some various kinds of oracle
uh you know it wants
to to run every step
uh you need a certain uh
subroutines operating on your function
class so if you have those
you can you know you can get efficient
algorithms
that being said that's a great question
to investigate further so i haven't
uh you know thought much along these
lines for specific say function classes
and so on so forth so we have a generic
algorithm that operates for any
uh
little stone game
uh but but yeah that's an interesting
thing to consider
yeah following up also on our work and
your
work with nika and so and so forth
uh okay so stochastic games so what are
stochastic games so stochastic games are
multi-player generalizations of markov
decision processes so in a market
decision process
you have a dyna like a system that is
reactive to your actions like in this
picture so roughly speaking
uh the system changes states and the
state transitions
are stochastic
and they depend on the current state and
your action at that state
so where you go next depends on your
current state and what you choose to do
at that stage
and also you receive rewards based on
uh
on its transition if you go from state
st to st plus one after you've taken
action a t you get some reward
and um
uh you know you can think of various
ways to behave in such an environment
maybe history dependent or history
independent
one of the
important
you know types of strategies are what
are called
stationary markov policies
stationary markov policies are policies
that specify a distribution of reactions
at every state
and do not have
these changing over time and stationary
and also this depending on the history
of what has happened so far they are
markov because they don't depend on the
history of what has happened so far but
just where you are right now and they
also don't change with time so they're
stationary okay this is what it means
the agent's goal is to optimize the
reward what is the reward the reward is
the
infinite sum of the rewards that they
receive in uh
expected rewards they receive in a
trajectory
uh using their policy
and so this expectation is you know you
start from some distribution sample from
some initialization distribution
and on every step t you choose an action
according to your policy
you make a transition according to the
transition uh
distribution
so that produces an infinite trajectory
you sum the rewards you accumulate on
this trajectory so this is your reward
from choosing
a in this case stationary markov policy
the analogous thing
generalizes if you have many agents
so now
the state transitions depend on the
actions of everybody
the rewards that people receive each
agent receives a reward
that depends not just on their own
actions and the states but also the
actions of the other people
again an interesting object to think
about
are stationary markov strategy policies
specifying for each player
what action they choose
at every state potentially distribution
over actions
and again every agent is interested in
optimizing their role
their own cumulative infinite reward
which is um
you know given the their own policy and
the police of the other people
i have an infinite expectation over the
starting state
the actions that all agents chose
along the way
and the state transitions which depend
on everybody's actions
and i'm i'm i'm accumulating the rewards
that are receiving this infinite
trajectory
okay
now what i wanted to point out is that
this function
of your stationary policy is not convex
or concave in your own policy
right
uh it's very non-convex in general right
because
you take that policy you use it in this
expectation you you plug it into this
reward function it's in general it's not
convex
even if you have a tabular like an
explicit representation
of you know like
this environment even if you have like a
finite number of actions
and you have an explicit representation
of this and that
your your uh uh rewards are not
uh
uh uh concave in your own policy just
because you know like you have to
compute uh respect to the stationary
with respect to the distribution of
trajectories that can arise from
everybody using their policy
so it's an interesting non-concave game
and uh it's super interesting because
despite the fact that it's a non-concave
game
nash equilibria exists
in markov stationary strategies under
very general conditions
basically the condition that you need is
that
with probability one
the game will stop
uh
you know by arriving at some sync state
where nothing happens
as long as that you have that you know
like at every round you chip off a
little bit probability going to that
sync state
as long as your game terminates with
probability one
and it's not like an infinite game
anything trajectory
uh
a stationary markov equilibria
so it's exists
surprising given the non-concavity of
the utility functions
uh in your own strategies
uh
right
which is an invitation for algorithms
algorithmists
right so you have what we have here we
have a non-concave game
that has global equilibria in this
stationary mark of strategies despite
the fact that the utilities are
non-concave so as an invitation for us
optimizers to start optimizing trying to
learn or computer equilibria in these
games
so here your your opponents are they
have to use stationary barcodes no
deviations or they can use any deviation
stationary markers
we play the game over stationary micro
strategies
so what do we know about algorithms uh
well on the
mdp setting there is
tons of work
both for the problem of computing
optimal policies and the problem of
learning optimal policies in an
environment that you do not fully
understand a priori
and
i'm not going to talk about that a lot
because you know dylan foster later this
week is going to actually dive into
exactly
dylan has done a lot of exciting work
recently on this problem and he will do
a whole tutorial on
uh mvps and and and uh
uh yeah alright
also i'm not going to dive too much on
the right hand side because see jean is
giving another tutorial on multi-agent
rl
but i just want to make a few remarks
uh first of all the problem that i'm you
know targeting here is
at least as hard as nash equilibria in
general some games
which are ppt complete
so it's not like some magic box like
will solve nash equilibria for me here
like
even if you have a single state
you have
the express express enough expressivity
to express any
normal from game
so um
the problem is intractable in general so
you have to focus on special cases
or special targets
if you want it to be tractable
so what are these targets well
first target with a lot of work recently
are two-player zero-sum games so
stochastic
two-player zero-sum games
there are a lot of methods recently
for learning and computing
equilibria in this special case
which generalizes you know the
phenomenon
setting and it's a non it's a case of a
non-concave zero-sum uh
uh game but uh where uh you know you can
trackably compute
the uh
uh mark of stationary mid max
equilibrium
the other target that has received some
attention especially in very recent
years
is correlated equilibrium
in this in the multiplayer version of
this game
so the multiplayer version of this game
generalizes normal form games in normal
form games
there's no uh issue of tractability for
corollary equilibria so the question is
can you compute corollary equilibria in
the stochastic version of multiplayer
games
i'll talk about that a little bit in a
second
uh and i want to carve out and again see
jane is going to cover all of that so i
just want to carve out some directions
from my perspective and you know and
then you know like gene will have the
floor to
uh analyze that further
so um one interesting question is
decoupled methods
lots of equilibrium computation and
learning methods for stochastic two
player zero sum games or correlated
equilibria in multiplayer cases
are centralized
so you have a central planner who's
optimizing the policies for all the
players at the same time
an interesting question is can you get
independent equilibrium learning can you
have the types of algorithms that we
know for normal form games where each
player is running their own regret
learning algorithm for example and the
joint behavior gets to correlated
equilibrium or min max equilibrium
we don't have much of that actually
there is some work on independent
equilibrium learning let me illustrate
uh one of these works that i was
involved with
um
and uh
with it and also take the opportunity to
you know talk a little bit about this
very nice special case of two-player
some stochastic games
the you know one cool thing about them
is that the mini max theorem holds for
stochastic station for stationary markov
policies
despite the non-concavity i was talking
about before so there's a lot of
structure in this setting
right so there's enough structure to
have a mini max theorem
so can you exploit this structure to get
gradient style or learning algorithms to
converge
to minimax equilibrium there must be
right there is a lot of structure
so does policy grading for example or
you know q learning or some other
you know algorithm like that converts to
a mini max and what types of structures
would enable you to do so
uh in a
in a paper with uh near go louis and
dylan foster
last year
we showed that
uh um
the games the the type of structures
that you can exploit to argue that
gradient
methods work
is a type of uh a gradient domination
condition
that allows you to argue that uh if you
find stationary points these are
actually
uh you know your duality gap is small
this is roughly what's taking place so
you can exploit the structure that is
there to argue that uh if people you
know if the two agents of your of your
of your game run independently policy
graded methods
then uh if you set the
learning rates appropriately you can get
convergence to
minimax
exploiting you know it's not a convex
problem but you have a lot of extra
structure
and it arises in the form of a gradient
domination condition
for our work there is other work that
exploits that you know that does not
analyze gradient
policy gradients but analyzes other
learning methods and
uh this is a little bit of a recent
theme
uh on on that front front
that's for two player zero zambians
stochastic games
how about correlated equilibria in
multiplayer stochastic games
so here we know very little and i hope
that this semester will contribute to
that to making progress there we know
very little
for computing corollary equilibriums
games
and and one thing i want to point out is
that
the papadi meteor ralph garden framework
for computing correlated equilibrium
that i mentioned earlier for games of
polynomial type
does not apply here because stochastic
games are not of polynomial type
deterministic strategies are what you
would do
in every state of the game
and they're exponentially many of those
so you do not have polynomial type
so you get you know some general purpose
algorithm to compute correlated
equilibria for you
so the question is what is the
complexity of the problem
so some recent work on this in this
space and and i expect uh
xi jin to talk about that
it has been able to
solve the
more easy cases of the problem where you
have a finite horizon
and you can do effectively backwards
induction to
compute correlate equilibrium
but uh
i don't know what's happening in general
but you don't have like a finite horizon
so that backwards induction works
it might be intractable or there could
be tractable variants of correlated
equilibrium
that's a very
i feel like
multi-agent rel is one of the
interesting frontiers on the multi-agent
learning uh
space
and uh
you know since nash equilibria are
intractable
it's very reasonable to target corollary
equilibria but we know very little about
those so i think that's a very
interesting problem to consider
uh yeah
likely
to have some some work
yeah i'll talk about that yeah uh
just next yeah
so
the other thing that uh uh another
important frontier is to add
incompleteness of information in this uh
on onto this problem so like in
stochastic
game model that i mentioned
the state is fully observable by
everybody and everybody choose their
actions
by after observing the states
uh in many scenarios of course you don't
fully mistake just you know maybe nature
has dealt cards to your opponents and
you don't know what cars have been built
uh nature who has uh given you certain
dna you don't know that unless you do
23andme or whatever so um
so um you know so there is a
completeness of information
uh importantly completes information
arises in you know to like you know
libra to some other you know like
uh recent
developments and uh i think an
interesting frontier on the multi-agent
learning set multi-agent rl setting is
to to add incompleteness of information
to that model as well and extend
uh then you know uh a very uh cool line
of work that we have for for extensive
form games which are
you know
with which are which are
games where you know that the the states
are are structured in a tree fashion
like what you see in in turn-based uh
games so over there we have uh
despite the fact that these are also of
non-polynomial type these extensive form
games are not a full number type
we have linear programming approaches
that compute minimax equilibria in the
tuple zero sum case
and we have uh ellipsoid against hope
methods that compute
a type of correlated equilibrium called
extensive form correlated
we also have an important line of work
on no regret learning that computes
either this or that
and what i want to propose is
generalizing those
results
from the extensive incomplete uh
extensive form uh game setting to the
incomplete uh or you know some special
cases of the incomplete stochastic
game
uh information stochastic game
setting
so let me wrap up
uh
by saying that you know mid max
optimization like this reputation are
classical questions
with intimate correction connections to
many disciplines and the foundations of
optimization and mathematics
and
you know classical they also have
classical applications in machine
learning and very recent applications in
machine learning those recent
applications
uh
pose big challenges because of the high
dimensionality and they're not concavity
of the utility functions of the agents
and
i you know in my tutorial what i tried
to do is to
chart the landscape
of uh what is possible
uh and what is challenging
uh you know when you consider the types
of models and questions
that arise in this space
thank you very much
remember we went five minutes overboard
i think we should take discussions
offline questions thank you very much